as you'll see i'm outside the king
edward the seventh hospital and
literally in the last few moments we
have seen the duke of edinburgh being
driven
away from the hospital that comes after
four weeks since he was admitted here to
the king edward the seventh
hopefully we can show you some of the
pictures now he was
in the back seat of a bmw he was wearing
a shirt it was quite
difficult to see him um however it was
unmistakably him
we are waiting for confirmation from the
palace that he has
left hospital and of course confirmation
of exactly
where he's going because it was two
weeks ago that we saw him
leave the king edward vii but he was
then taken to
saint bart's hospital and just to recap
on exactly why prince philip has been in
hospital it was
four weeks ago that he was admitted we
were told at the time
that he was able to walk into the
hospital it wasn't an emergency
admission
then a few days later it was confirmed
that he was being treated for
some kind of infection again the palace
wouldn't say
exactly what it was then two weeks ago
that we saw him
being moved from here at the king edward
the seventh church of bart's hospital
which
is really a specialist heart hospital
and we were told that he was being moved
there
to be treated yes for the infection but
also for an underlying
heart condition it was then two weeks
ago again that it was confirmed that he
had undergone some kind of heart
procedure
again the pal is not confirming exactly
what but we know that back in 2011
he was fitted with a coronary strength
coroni's stent
because of a blocked artery and yeah for
the last two weeks he was then brought
back here to the king edward vii
and of course last week a very busy week
for the royal family when it came to
contending with the fallout
of the aftermath of prince of prince
harry and megan's interview with oprah
and there were no updates about prince
philip so we could only assume that he
was in hospital
being monitored recovering but yeah in
the last
few moments or so he has left hospital
after a huge amount of police activity
here this morning
we anticipated that something may be
happening we saw a
large number of police officers uh
gathering also police outriders
and then yeah about five minutes ago saw
the duke of edinburgh being driven
away from the hospital yet to be
confirmed exactly where he's gone
at the palace still confirmed that he
has left hospital and where he's going
our ariana thanks for that